- And here's the thing I love about you.
You're so normal.
(audience laughs)
When we were at the
AMAs, you were hosting.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "Oh my God, I love her."
I'm sitting here going off,
and all of a sudden I'm like,
"Why is Diana Ross gettin'
onstage with all her family?"
(laughter)
I was like, I had no--
- I love that.
- This is 2017.
(audience laughs)
Like, that this happened, and I had no,
I'm like a fan of you and I had no idea.
- [Tracee] Love that.
- [Kelly] But that's--
- [Tracee] It means my career worked.
- No, you're so good,
you're so talented!
- Thank you.
- I had no idea, and
then it kinda made sense
that talent doesn't
fall far from the tree.
But I was like, "Wow!"
(laughter)
Then I was like, "You're so normal."
I would've never guessed
that you would've grown up in
Hollywood, I would've
never guessed you grew up--
- Well I didn't grow up in Hollywood.
I grew up in my mom's
house, you know what I mean?
(laughter)
- Well okay, okay.
- But we, and we weren't in Hollywood.
We didn't live here.
- Oh, really?
- Only when I was little.
- And you didn't go out or
anything, you weren't that--
- No, and I mean I was,
my mom is such a mom.
She's a mom before she's anything else.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And so, I just had a really--
- That's why you're great!
- Yeah, I had like a
really regular upbringing.
I got a lot of siblings,
you know what I mean?
- Me too.
- My mom was always like,
"This money is not for you,
"this money is for me."
- That's me!
- Know what I mean?
- My kids are like, "We have money,"
I'm like, "No, sir,
"I have money."
- "No, no, no, I have money."
(laughter)
- "You're broke, you ain't got any money!"
- You didn't do a thing!
- Yeah, I'm spending all of this,
you better get a job.
- That's what she
that's exactly what she used to say to us!
- [Kelly] Yeah, yes.
- She was like,
- I just bought a ranch!
- "I don't know you better
figure out what you're doing!"
- I hope y'all figure it out! Yeah I'm--
- She's like, "I'll pay for doctors
"and make sure there's
a roof over your head."
"Until a certain point!"
- Education, yep.
- "And then go on."
- I'll pay for health and education
- Yeah.
- Nothing else.
- (laughs) That's it!
- 'Cause you know what?
I turned out just fine.
And I didn't have anything.
I worked hard, so, yes.
(audience cheers)
- That's exactly right!